[Music]
these things are good Diamond heads yeah
I love them yeah
and then you know hungry as hell
so defeated I'm hungry as hell uh well I
got me a protein uh protein Pop-Tart
wait what is that Alina got these
protein Pop-Tarts yeah that's like one
of these you know it's probably just
like a protein bar just remixed into a
shape yeah it's just Play-Doh
protein Play-Doh that's all protein bars
are
dude I can't eat those without just
getting so gassy
so gassy I ate some [__] protein
oatmeal the other day oh see ya you see
these like overnight oats everyone see
you are you kidding me broke my God like
8 A.M to noon was hell yeah dude hot
boxing my car bro yeah
just heavy yeah farting just hot sick
ass you know I love bro I love when
you'll see a uh
a workout diet suggestion in the little
show so I do half a cup of oatmeal
and then just a scoop of protein one cup
of whey protein yeah I love how they say
just a scoop of protein like those two
things aren't going to give you diarrhea
yeah yeah yeah it's like as soon as you
eat that you're [__] your brains out
I don't even get it's not I don't get
like runny [__] I get like bloated and
it's like my body doesn't know it like
my [__] turns to like thick sludge and
it's like hard to even get it out of my
body I want to eat this now that you
said that I'm just saying that's the way
like whey protein is so unnatural yeah I
can just tell by the way my body like
tries to process it look at this dude
let me piece of that though
look at these sprinkles yeah what the
[__] is that I need my full 20 grams
trying to hit my macros these fake ass
sprinkles this just looks like paint
yeah
yeah they're just flat let's just have a
taste
that's actually the mold of my dick
oh
good
looks like a protein bar you know you
can get these things on Amazon
oh
this tastes like space food yeah
protein [__] doesn't taste good
I hate how they try to trick us wait are
you trying to get more protein that
thing's also like 20 grams isn't it yeah
I think it's 24. what are you doing 30.
40 grams of protein
what's up man lifting again oh yeah I
mean I'm trying to keep it on yeah the
tour diet man
gets to you yeah I've actually found
that
I've eaten way less on tour okay yeah so
much that's all we do
what do you eat though Thai food yeah
[__] four meals a day now we've um we we
leave Thai food you know that had its
time yeah that had a special place yeah
time time some of the venues had like
some fire chili nuggets yeah like
chicken nuggets uh the the Knitting
Factory in Boise I don't know what they
did to that food holy [__] so you like
Boise
oh yeah did you see the Blink 182 Club
yeah yeah yeah yeah I was dying at that
you posted do you like I was watching
live and I was like [__] man
that's really good we're in India
did you ever listen to Blink 182 not
like that
so did you like got no like feelings
from watching no
damn dude I when that popped up in my
feed like the first weekend the clips
from the oh my live streams I actually
would like a piece I'm so hungry you
want the other side hmm okay
oh yeah it's not good
dude that tastes like runoff
dude from a protein powder Factory I
feel like you're just
make this my stomach is [__] genuinely
dude I'm actually burfing from this
like uh
like this that comes out of the machines
yeah
you know you know this tastes like the
first time you took protein powder and
you didn't mix it properly yeah and and
like eat your Shaker balls sucked
so you're just getting chunks of it in
water yeah and you're going at the end
yeah and yeah you're just eating out a
[__] yeah okay can I get another yeah
go ahead
pause it kind of good
[Laughter]
oh you're supposed to heat it up too oh
that's where I [__] up she said you
have to heat it for 10 seconds otherwise
it tastes ass damn
um
I can't then
those things are Fitness food is crazy
yeah
Elena's been coming home with some crazy
[__] lately like what she's been fooling
around with those Quest chips oh okay
yeah 20 grams of protein yeah
but I'm like actually mine those I'm
skeptical you think this is an actual
protein in there
uh what do you mean it's like it's a
fake protein no like like
protein that can actually affect your
body growth I have no idea how that
should works at a certain point it's
like okay you can't really make healthy
versions of certain things yeah chips
are just chips yeah
but I guess hey if you're gonna dust
them with some whey yeah I guess yeah
Totino's chips
Tostitos make popcorn yeah and just
Delight dusting let's take it around
yeah it's cheddar protein popcorn
I that probably exists yeah that
definitely exists you know we gotta open
in La dude a fitness oriented movie
theater
you know any idiots we'd have in there
yeah
oh no they're they're way infused milk
though and it's good protein popcorn
yeah
this is horrendous
a fitness movie theater
by the way if you're listening on audio
that's the sound of the treadmill in the
gym [__] 15 of them
trying to watch Avatar
shut up you know what I prefer I prefer
working out at the Crunch Fitness
in the middle of North Carolina yeah and
some old heads walking up to me in the
middle of my workout being like
see you better put on more than that you
want to grow
that's a good that's a good disc yeah
really good disc yeah and I'm like
I'm not there well I'm working up to it
okay they're gone yeah
that's good that would make you feel
like [__] you know what's awesome I was
I was squatting uh a measly little just
two plates
you know I was somewhere and then um
this lesbian girl I think she had just
finished like
dead lifting it was a [__] ton of weight
it was a lot of plates
she like slams it down and she pops her
headphones out she's like yo you know
what Miller
and then I just wanted to be like I'm
sorry I had to see that I felt like I
let her down yeah like maybe she like
enjoys my comedy and then she's like uh
yeah you see you're on like Des Moines
later yeah Noelle Miller yeah
spotted
[__] ass way pounds [__] ass weight
struggling that was a lesbian yeah
yeah
nah nah come on my lesbians know I know
are you Noel Miller yeah are you a
lesbian she's like yes yes and we dap
each other up yeah
then we hug it out